and we're live again welcome back to the
show this is hans kim
tonight we're talking about
um
florida florida
really the best state
i mean it has a high concentrations of
riley's in it which makes it nice
um
florida is great if you like
to party
or if you have
a beautiful body
yeah
if you like spray tans
if you go to fsu
florida is the place to be
hell yeah
the right-handed tomahawk
i can do this
one of you now
florida is good if you want to go to a
college that's also a cult
yeah [ __ ] uf
that's like a thing that they hate each
other even though they secretly like
each other
they say florida is good for mom
daughter hookups
do you have a florida man story
well there's this coke dealer a reformed
coke dealer that runs a comedy club that
booked me for a comedy show
which is pretty fun
why uh why do we need red band is the
audio sound bad but yeah he was a crazy
man and he had like lots of jewelry and
my opener for
the shows in florida in uh
new smyrna beach
was this 19 year old and we all went to
a bar afterwards and the bartender the
bar bouncer wouldn't let the 19 year old
in and this coke dealer was like don't
worry i got you just watch and then he
tried to get him in
and he failed
he was like can you let him in he's like
nah
yeah
they're all just going around
pretending like they own the place
and they're trying to use their [ __ ]
advantage of occupying physical space
in
florida to uh
try to
gain power and prestige and
sexual favors
yeah the feed dropped off and it's back
it was weird i think it was either the
internet or obs
i have met ron white i've had very
in-depth conversations with him
and i've
grown to respect him more than i already
did
and he was a great hero to me and it's
amazing that i get to meet him and talk
to him and introduce him on stage
it's so crazy because i do all these
vulcan shows with
joe rogan
and
he uh
he brings out some of the best comedians
in the world so i got to introduce
duncan trussell i got to introduce ron
white i got to introduce shane gillis
mark normand ari shafir
uh
[Music]
some of the best comedians theo vaughn
so you could say that i'm privileged
um but yeah i mean i'm super happy with
where i'm at i'm just trying not to [ __ ]
it up so
don't mess with me
because it might send me over the edge
and then i might lose my job
but yeah i mean
um
yeah i did a podcast recently with dr
drew pinsky
doctor extraordinaire and he
talked a lot about sexual diseases on
the penis and the anus and stuff
and it's just great because like so much
of that stuff is so hard to talk about
uh and it's like everyone wants to keep
it quiet but like he does it publicly
which is very needed
because then it's like
then people aren't hiding it then we all
know
what
genital health looks like
by watching the podcast and we don't
have to like you know expose ourselves
to each other literally and figuratively
um
i think that uh
it should be coming out in like a couple
months but
yeah uh a whole bunch of kill tony
people went and did his podcast
so dr drew
yeah dr drew after dark or doctor
whatever i don't know what the specific
name is i don't think he i think he only
has one podcast or maybe he has multiple
but um yeah a bunch of us killed tony
people went on his podcast so that
should be coming out soon
um
hans are you stoned you look extremely
high but it could just be asian eyes
these people they always say the same
thing
i just have a really chill energy
i'm just like a really
low
you know i'm really like
comfortable and i'm not gonna like yell
at you or like blue
go like spazz out and [ __ ]
so uh there's a court case going on oh
the alex jones court case is going on
which is sort of interesting
uh apparently his lawyers accidentally
texted the other the prosecutors all of
his text messages on accident
so kind of a bone-headed move
um
kind of like a mistake i would i would
think
um but i think it's happening right here
in austin so that's interesting
i've met alex jones he's a very nice man
i think that what happened with sandy
hook is horrible
and it's horrible if people lost their
children and then people are accusing
them of being fake obviously that's not
good
but uh yeah i think uh
that's for the course to decide me on
the other hand i will
continue to
enjoy alex jones's presence whenever i
see him whenever i have the privilege to
be near him and the force of energy and
nature that he is
a very interesting human
uh you know very unique and very uh
strong and you know he is uh
authentically himself he is just he
talks a lot but he talks a lot because
that's what he
actually feels and stuff
but uh
yeah i mean i think like uh
i think alex jones is like a
very talented person in terms of
entertainment
and uh
unfortunately we have a very toxic
society that isn't utilizing him
correctly
um
but i think pure entertainment value
you're gonna it's gonna be hard to top
him
um but yeah what else is going on in the
news
um
news
statement by president biden on the
sentencing of wrongfully oh apparently
she brittany griner was sentenced to
nine years in prison
for having weed on her which is just
like a political thing the russians are
like let's [ __ ] with this american
because we have her and they're
sanctioning us
so i think that's wrong
i wish i had funny takes on this stuff
i'm just saying basic things really
i'm just saying like what i feel and i
feel like brittany griner should not be
in jail
um
uh
yeah i mean people are
saying that she deserves it whatever
[ __ ] her but i mean
we should try to help her if we can
i mean we can help everyone we can help
people wrongfully imprisoned in america
and people wrongfully imprisoned in
russia like we can do both it doesn't
have to be one or the other
and it definitely doesn't have to be
neither we should be trying to do both
definitely instead of neither
which is what happens like why aren't
you fixing this instead of fixing that
and then when you try to fix that then
you're like why are you fixing that
instead of fixing this
and so nothing ever gets fixed
but you know you don't have to be doing
the most good like if you donate to a
charity for
blind
uh
midgets that have
four toes
like that's still a good thing you don't
have to donate your money in the most
efficient way possible just the fact
that you're doing good is good that
you're pushing the needle in the correct
direction so i think
we should be more
into
helping
wherever the issue and whatever happens
to interest you
help in that way
if you're
interested in
you know
little
little uh
women who
want to get bigger
like that's
you can help with that if that's
something that you are
interested in
i heard that there were empty cartridges
and just had my new traces of thc
riley what do you think about brittany
griner
i told you
do you want to
keep her in jail and make her speak
russian
um
i mean i don't think we should trade who
we're planning on trading for
brenda griner
the person that we want to give up to
get her out of jail
not sure if it's worth it
i mean she broke the law she's lived
there before she knows what the laws are
so you're like
uh floored floridian about this
you're like
you're like polk county sheriff about
this
i just
don't think we should be trading
like whatever he i don't
he was a weapons dealer he sold weapons
to nigeria and they used to shoot down a
plane
[Music]
well
for a girl who looks like she can hold
her out in prison
just because you can hold your own in
prison doesn't mean it's going to be a
pleasant experience
i'm sure it's not going to be a pleasant
experience i
don't know a lot about russian prisons
but i'm sure they're not fun
yeah they're not known for their
for their activities and
uh
recreation recreational time
russian
prisons
yeah i mean she [ __ ] up
i mean don't you think that we should
give her a second chance
how many like u.s citizens do you think
are in russian prisons like there's
gotta be a lot more than just her but
we're only fighting to get her out
because she's famous
because we noticed her
yeah
so we shouldn't notice
if when things like that happen
you should be like oh we're just going
to treat you
as shitty as we treat everyone else
that are
in prison for some reasons overseas
i think they were trying to trade
brittany griner and some spy
for this weapons dealer
so it's bringing attention to this other
guy you know she's using her fame to
like
let people know about this other
american that was in jail in russia so
isn't that helpful
well you know
we all know how you feel about brittany
griner you know
i uh
i hope that uh you never go to russia
because then it's gonna be hard to get
you out after seeing this
probably
i mean if if you were in prison in
russia i would
i'd be like
it was cbd
it was delta eight
i'd be trying to argue for you
thing
i don't know if you could get me out but
thanks for trying
yeah
i could pretend i'm north korean
russians and north koreans like each
other
[Music]
because they're both
trying to nuke the world
yeah we're both
the axis of evil
i'm a i'm south korean though
i'm good korean now you don't want to
see my north korean side
i'm a lot skinnier
and sadder
i don't think they had the farm bill in
russia
i don't know what that means
uh
i'd grinder on you if you were here girl
bigfoot phil says that he would grind
her on you
how does that make you yeah
i don't know what i look like
no
okay
and that's weird
bigfoot phil is
he's going to grind her on anything he
can he's he's a hideous
oaf of a ape
he
he'll take whatever he can get
um you know brianna taylor is in the
news
i mean she's dead but
the people that murdered her are on the
news
god this is a sad show isn't it
this is the news this is the world is
sad what am i supposed to do live in a
fake world maybe i should look up happy
news florida governor ron desantis
that's your guy
no
suspense state attorney andrew warren he
suspended
an attorney tallahassee democrat
accused of being woke not enforcing laws
oh my god i bet he just suspended him
for not being mean enough to poor people
slash black people
so it's like a persecution of uh
politics it's like even though he was
democratically elected
they [ __ ] they're like we don't like
we're gonna fight and try to keep
democracy down
and what do you guys think of ron
desantis what if they would keep her
till we forget so they have her on their
russian basketball team yeah what do you
think about that you think that maybe
they're trying to bolster their lineup
and they're just keeping her and they're
going to use her to coach the women's
basketball team
can she play basketball when she's in
prison
i think that's all she can do
they usually have hoops in basketball in
a jail that's the
from what i see on tv but
it's going to be hard to dribble on the
snow
good luck in
[Music]
brittany griner
florida is a weird state right because
it's like
there's there's like it's pretty like it
almost went to biden
did it go to biden the last election
they're like weirdly
not southern they're like southern but
not really southern
who
the uh
florida politics
oh
i mean this whole thing about like
attorney generals being too woke and not
arresting enough people i think is just
addressing the symptoms and not the
cause if you want to reduce crime then
you got to address poverty poverty leads
to crime and to just be like you're not
arresting enough people and you're not
torturing enough poor people i think is
a horrible inhumane solution if people
are starving and
in shitty living situations they're
going to steal
because
that's the only way out of their
situation the the proper channels of
work
during uh playing by the rules is not
working for them
so
until you address poverty i think just
being mean and having draconian criminal
laws is not
a humane solution it'll f it won't even
fix the problem it'll only be a band-aid
i think the real root causes poverty if
there's less poor people scrounging
around and being
desperate and gross then there's going
to be less crime
um but my friend is dead
oh my god what can i do the operator
says calm down i can help first let's
make sure oh it's a joke let's make sure
he's dead and then
he here's a here's a bang and he's like
okay now what
it's like uh
i i googled it like what is the funniest
joke the joke that works across all
cultures and that's
one of the jokes that was in there when
i was like
in
like 12 years ago when i was your age
rightly
yeah
when i was a wee little pup like you
you think about you dating a girl or
talking to a girl 10 years younger than
well you're 11 years younger than me
what do you guys think about me dating
riley who's 11 years younger than me
one guy says hell yeah brother
get that
no that's just me i said that
um
yeah i mean
i think that uh
i like it
but not because of your age i think it's
just
that's just how old you happen to be and
then you happen to be
amazing and gorgeous
uh and we get along very well i'd like
to think even over ft
episode hasn't come out yet so they
don't even know about the ft chronicles
it comes out in two weeks
uh forever a ride says she's lucky to
have that experienced asian meat
what do you think about that generous
chicken
huh
what do you think about generous chicken
that's what i call my penis
oh
very well done
oh
knows what it's doing down there
it's not too tough is it
no sometimes it might be a little too
big but i mean
oh [ __ ]
thank you for putting that on the
internet
i'm very proud to break stereotypes
i also am very bad at math
that's a lie
he graduated college
that's true i have graduated 10 years
ago
tell them what you graduated in
mechanical engineering
and eating [ __ ]
i mean it happened so long ago it
doesn't even feel like me
i mean
is college
really that formative of an experience
maybe for people that
are
attractive and cool and party animals
but for me i was just
studying and
you know being a good student and not
going to bars with pools in it
i've been trying to lose weight i've
been buying lighters and yet to see my
result
they say smoking helps you lose weight i
don't know
teeth weighed so much
i don't know what the [ __ ] kind of joke
he's trying to say
i've been buying lighters
i've been doing this little bit nowadays
where if uh somebody steals a lighter
i'll be like to the guy that got stolen
i'll be like you're a lighter lighter
isn't that super clever
anyways can you weld something no
did you sell your van i want it i'm
almost certain it has super powers
well i built that [ __ ] from
bare bones to what it is now i replaced
all the electric electrical components
i put solar panels on that puppy
i have a tv in it if i want to hook it
up
i have
a heater i have a fan i have a sink in
it i have a bed
it is my creation and i loved being able
to create something that i could live in
because then um
everything is where i want it and i can
fix anything i need which i'm not a good
craftsman so there was a lot of fixing
that needed to be done
but it was just customizable and it it
felt good to be in something that i made
like so many of the things and places
that i'm in i have no connection to
like this room that i'm currently
residing in like
i don't know who made it i don't know
how it was made i just i just sort of
plop myself down in it but like in the
van i know what's behind every wall
i know
uh
i know what to do if things break like
if something breaks here i have to call
some i have to call a man a real man
to fix it but in my van i am the man
there is no man besides me that knows
how to fix it because i probably did
everything incorrectly
so i did everything the wrong way so no
one's going to be able to know
how to fix it
but yeah that van is an extension of me
in some way
i'm like iron man except my suit is very
big and
not that cool
it's just good for
sleeping in
um
it doesn't shoot anything
uh it's just good for
it's like a sauna now
do you ever like go in your car and use
it as a sauna
or is there no point because that it's
so hot outside that it's like it doesn't
matter
i think that's cool that we all have a
sauna now
uh does does your girlfriend have nice
skin
he says the type that you would wear
yeah these people are crazy i don't know
why i read that out loud
you probably got a good payday on the
way out i had an 89 corvette i bought
for 3 500. i cut the roof and exhaust
off and got the 3 500 on the way up
car maker went way up since you got it
mark it went way up i haven't sold it
yet i still have it it's sitting in my
driveway i also have a rental
but it's my daily driver i drive that
[ __ ] everywhere i just got it back i got
it fixed i've spent seven thousand
dollars fixing this puppy which is
almost as much as i bought it for
i think
which is crazy
but yeah now it's all fixed up
that's ready to go
um i want to take it camping but right
now it's too hot
uh so i'm just sitting in my
air-conditioned home waiting for the
weather to cool down so i can take that
puppy out on the road
i could go up north but you know i have
to drive pretty far to get to somewhere
habitable and also i'm super busy
uh
and i would rather just wait until like
december or november when the weather is
perfect in texas and then i can just
drive 30 minutes but the thing about
texas is there's no pro
public there's no public land in texas
so
it makes it really difficult to
camp
it makes it really difficult to camp in
texas unless you have money which i do
um now i do i can brag about it because
i used to be so poor and i was very open
with my poorness it didn't define me and
now my
wealth doesn't define me either so
either way it boils down it does not
define me
so
um i was uh
making fun of how poor i was when i was
poor and now that i have
entered into lower middle class
i can brag about that
i'm so rich that i might just have a
baby for fun
just so i can spend some money
riley still has her whole life to live
she doesn't want to be tied down by some
nagging little
nagging little
parasite
uh yes i was teased by hans and franz
skit on the snl growing up
hey hans question who wins predator
versus tyrant from resident evil
well the thing about the snl
quips and the hans from hans landa from
glorious bastards and hans from uh die
hard it's like it's just a reference
they're like hey remember this it's just
like a callback to something that
happened before there's nothing more to
it it's hard to add more to an snl
sketch because it's already funny like
it's hard to make something funny that's
already funny funny
but yeah i've been called many names
because of my weird germanic name
uh it's not a common name for an asian
to have so it's obviously gonna be
eye-catching and weird
hans have you ever been to europe have
you ever thought of hitting up comedy
festivals kill kenny in ireland and
edinburgh
edinburgh
fringe and scotland
is awesome they would love you
yeah i would love to go to england and
europe uh you know it's just a bit of a
hike it's a bit of a far plane trip
and uh life is pretty good in america
i would love to you know go for the
festivals and just explore and travel
and broaden my horizons
it's just like
the number of joe rogans in england is
very low
and in austin it has the perfect number
of joe rogans and tony hinchcliffe's
so
i'd rather just stay here
um but it's really hard for me to
schedule anything because my schedule
really revolves around
the uh bigger
names and my
comedy mentors that i'm currently
studying under
so i have to be there for them and right
now i'm in an apprenticeship
and i am
an apprentice for one of the
best mentors in the world right now and
it's not an opportunity that i want to
give up you know a lot of people would
pay a lot of money to uh spend time and
have that quality time
with my mentors that i'm getting paid
for and i i want to respect and honor
that time and this relationship that i
have
by being a little [ __ ] and
changing my whole life for them which is
great because my life before wasn't that
great to begin with so it's very easy to
change for them
but yeah i don't uh i'm asian so i don't
have this like uh you know i gotta be my
own man and i'm gonna be doing
everything on my own i'm like asian so
i'm like oh yeah there's elders and you
gotta respect your elders
and i just uh you know try to be an
asian
uh and be a very respectful asian
and hierarchy and respecting
respecting my elders so that i can one
day uh you know
be as great as them hopefully and learn
from them and just improve as a person
and you know like the concept of an
individual is
an illusion it's a very helpful illusion
but it's also uh
you know i should i don't want it to tie
me down so that i'm not learning from
the best and
interacting with uh amazing people that
i can improve from and making my
individual self better by
suppressing my individuality for a quick
second while i
improve upon my personality by learning
from others
and inhabiting their mindset and their
way of being i hope uh that makes sense
uh if when you get the opportunity to go
on rogan you should mention aliens and
fun obscure topics your intellectual
personality would be very fun to listen
to
on stuff like that i don't really talk
about aliens that much
it's sort of like uh
i know
i'm uh
talking in front of alien homes the home
of aliens talking about how i don't
believe in them
it's kind of sacrilegious i'm being
really rude to aliens right now
um
what did you think about uncle laser i
thought he was amazing i thought he was
funny he's a great character he's a
great personality
uh do you know who uncle laser is riley
riley isn't a kill tony head
i'm trying to convert her
um i thought he was great you know he is
obviously jealousy inducing uh in the
best possible way because he's so
natural and it comes so easily to him
but uh yeah i uh
i think he's an amazing person a great
personality
uh and uh i hope that he continues and i
hope to
uh meet him again or see him again and
uh you know i hope he grows and hope we
can
foster him and be nice to him and just
make sure that he i mean he's like such
he's like already a big he's like a man
so i don't know how much i could foster
him
but i think he's like a big personality
he's like hey what are you doing you
know what they say when you're in prison
you got to have two
knuckles in your bud and one knuckle and
some snickers and he just like talks in
phrases and sayings and [ __ ]
but yeah he's uh he's a very quick
thinker and his phrases actually make
sense
and are appropriate for the question
that was asked
so pawns hope you don't forget the
monkey pox hope you don't get the monkey
pox from kissing all the
red all the those red rose and yellow
girls rose girls best of luck man
well i have stopped kissing strippers
that was old news but um yeah so far i'm
good
huh
riley is not a stripper she is
an fsu graduate
which doesn't miss
even if you
fifteen hundred dollars
if you pay riley fifteen hundred dollars
she will become a stripper
but she hasn't yet
so technically not a stripper
just a beautiful young lady in florida
who works at a comedy club
which she calls comedy club
this is the only one in
naples hey i'm uncle laser and i [ __ ]
love
my mullet you guys ever see a dead
possum on the side of the road
that's what i call a [ __ ]
oh god i can't do it
i can only be myself
alcoholism certificates at fsu
did she go to class or the beach more
tallahassee's kind of far from the beach
i learned this from riley
i know but when you went to fsu
she's an alcoholic
that's just called
being
a party animal
that's just called being
a good hang
if you don't drink in college that's
called being a party pooper
yes uh vorak if you would like to brand
edit you can please look at my youtube
and clip anything you want
yes vorak please clip stuff uh i usually
pay 10 bucks for clip
so
it's not nothing
i've been been watching kill tony a
little no joke last four days straight
that's what i used to do especially
during the pandemic when there was no
social interactions it was my only i was
like watching people talk to each other
like one day i'll be out of this
van and i'll talk to a person just like
tony does and joel jimenez and
jeremiah watkins and
david lucas and william montgomery and
now i know all them except for joelberg
so it's crazy it's just
uh crazy that i got to uh be on the show
that i used to watch
and that i was a huge fan of hans when
you come to tacoma in december i'll take
you crabbing and fishing you have time
if you have time
uh yeah i love
love to eat
i ate some seafood yesterday
um
i just didn't know that it was that big
in seattle
uh but uh seattle was home to the only
uh
they were like uh sedentary
they only stayed in one spot in seattle
the native americans in seattle stayed
in one spot and just like ate fish all
day because there's so much food there
so it's like a very bountiful place to
live
thank you vorak
vorak is
gonna work is going to edit clips for me
so um
what else is going on
as monkeyprox spreads u.s plans to
declare a health emergency
it's just like the first panda the
coronavirus pandemic that we went
through everyone just got angry and
everyone was just like i'm not doing
[ __ ]
uh and so i don't know if we're gonna be
prepared for the next pandemic i don't
think that we have the right mindset
like if another pandemic hits they're
gonna be like oh we've been through this
before we don't have to do anything [ __ ]
you
and we're just gonna let it spread like
if a pandemic hits right now that would
be the perfect time for the pandemic
thinking as a virus
this would be the perfect time because
everyone's guard is down everyone's
exhausted no one has any stamina no one
can stay out of applebee's for more than
three weeks
and if a pandemic hit right now it would
spread like wildfire because no one
would do anything to stop it
but hopefully it doesn't happen
um and that's the best we can do the
survival of our species relies upon the
virus
a virus not popping up we have no
defenses if it does pop up
uh
we just have to hope it doesn't because
our interest in consumerism and shopping
trumps our need to
survive as a species
um i mean i just feel like you can do
whatever you want you just can't go into
society however you want society has
some requirements before you enter it
you can still live out in the woods you
don't have to wear a mask in the woods
you can like chop wood all day hunt bear
and like
fart up a storm but if you want to enter
society you got to make sure that you're
not hurting society
and i think that's a very reasonable
requirement but if everyone in a society
is like we're all going to not give a
[ __ ] about diseases
then you can enter that society because
they don't care it's just like not a
very sustainable
way to have a society if you're just
gonna ignore diseases
but i'm asian i love the government
i love overarching control and hive
minds
and i
want the government to tell me
what to do and how i should be as a
person
no i'm just kidding i don't want the
government to do that i just think that
uh you know planning is very useful
and
i think
you know like people
working together is better than everyone
working on their own it's more efficient
to have everyone pitch in
and make a swimming pool then everyone
have their own individual swimming pool
that they use once every week
but yeah i don't think working together
has to be this horrible thing i don't
think it has to mean that you're
pathetic or whatever
i think working together is beautiful
and the future of humanity and how we
got to where we are
we didn't get here by fighting with each
other
although we did fight with each other a
lot
anyways how should austin address
homelessness the city wants your input
um
how about
the best way to address homelessness is
to give them homes
that way you'll eradicate homelessness
people be like you gotta have mental
health you gotta have drug
addiction counseling just give them
homes and let them figure it out
but you think people need to be babysit
you need to hold their hands
and teach them how not to be a fuck-up
they're a fuck-up because they don't
have enough money
if they have enough money they would be
just like you and me maybe a little more
eccentric
but yeah i don't i don't think that we
should baby people i think that if we
give them homes in a decent society and
a different decent uh
life that people will generally be good
i mean we treat people shitty now and
people are still generally good
so imagine how much better people will
be if we give them basic human rights
and guarantee their safety
anyways
um
what's some news that riley would be
into
let's look up tmz
news
machine gun kelly tour bus vandalized
with homophobic slur
riley
our senior tmz correspondent what do you
think about
machine gun kelly tour bus vandalizes
homophobic slur
is this homophobic
this isn't homophobic it's just a
picture of a penis
with
[ __ ] coming out of it or pee coming out
of it
i don't think that's homophobic oh he
they wrote [ __ ] on it that's
homophobic
devil
that actually sounds like a compliment
they call them a rap devil
is this like some sort of christian
thing or they're like you're spreading
demonic music you're corrupting the
youths
um but yeah i mean the
conservative uh
you know
uh whatever's
like the old people they just don't
understand art and they uh
their whole personality is developed to
be against
uh change or like i'm just gonna do the
right thing and gonna do everything the
right way
and then when they see someone doing
like the complete opposite of that not
living in the suburbs and having a nice
quiet life they're like how come he gets
to do that and i had to do this
and they want everyone to do what
they're doing
because then they're they won't
they won't be the only ones not having
fun
so they just want people to not have fun
basically
that's my opinion
so they draw dicks on things
like if if they are like a christian
type of like old
people type of thing like
the fact that they drew a dick is pretty
pretty badass
for them
but yeah i mean i think artists are
misunderstood
huh
on the job resume under gender you can
decline the answer
yeah with your name you you could be
considered a man that might help you out
i'm just thinking about your job
prospects
we're applied to three jobs today i am
done
good job riley
we're all proud of you
all the kim cells and hans heads
um
what do you think about the exploitative
nature of job applications don't you
think that a lot of it is useless busy
work that they want you to do to prove
your loyalty
well i want to do the busy work because
that's all i'm qualified for right now
don't say that you're a beautiful human
with creativity and
i ran out of nicotine and i don't have a
car to go
riley accidentally crashed her car
because she's a woman
no she didn't
oh you don't want that out there
no
not with everything still open
it wasn't her fault
it was actually someone else's fault
um but yeah i just feel like the whole
job application process is like
it takes forever to apply for jobs
and you have to do that full-time not
getting paid for it and it's like
unnecessary
like if you really
want to know about someone
you should interview them you shouldn't
just like make them fill out the same
information what's your address what's
your phone and why do people ask for
your address like they think that's okay
like you don't need to know where i
sleep
please don't ask for that
i can't believe how many people i've
told my address to
this is why i used to live in a van when
i lived in a van it felt so great
because no one knew where i was sleeping
i didn't even know where i would be
sleeping that night
but now i live in a house everyone knows
where i sleep now my [ __ ] mechanic
knows the goddamn comedy club asks for
my address
everyone needs to know where i sleep
like they need to be able to come and
bust through my doors and shoot me in
the head if i if they gave me like
200
like now i get to know your address
is that not how they do it at fsu
i was making fun of you for going to fsu
oh his song is called rap devil why did
they vandalize do you think this
vandalization was actually like
a compliment
okay this has been popping up on the
normal news and on tmz news four cops
charged in connection to raid that
killed brianna taylor
isn't that crazy
obama out with the mystery man
good for her
she is a young woman
whose dad
is a great president
or was
um and now
she's out with a man
everyone deserves love and malia obama
is now loving someone who wears the same
colored pants as she does
are they touching oh he's touching her
back they're walking arm and arm
they definitely [ __ ]
justin bieber offers to help bring
britney griner back to us
if i was in prison in russia and they
were like don't worry justin bieber is
on the case i'd be like oh [ __ ]
let me get comfortable
let me start making friends
i mean what can justin bieber do he's
canadian
he has even less power
than americans do he can't even nuke
russia if you wanted to
pilot who died during emergency may have
fallen looking at landing gear
that's horrible
pilot who died during emergency may have
fallen looking at landing gear
maybe he was like
on the plane trying to look at the
landing gear and he fell
um
you want to look through my instagram
there's william montgomery with this
oh [ __ ]
brazilian jiu jitsu black belt subdued
serial attacker in new york
my god i love these videos jiu-jitsu in
action
and they're just
laying on top of some dude in public and
everyone's like what are you doing
and they're like i'm doing good i'm a
hero
this guy's got his calf right in his
crotch
that's sexually humiliating
but jiu jitsu is like the most
embarrassing way to lose to someone
because i mean i guess getting knocked
out is pretty embarrassing too but with
jiu jitsu you can make them into a
little pretzel and you can like
make them uh into whatever shape you
want
so
it's pretty embarrassing
and
you can make smush their face into the
pavement or whatever you want
like a lot of these cops don't really
know how to do grappling that well
uh and i saw a video where they were
trying to subdue someone and they were
just like laying on their legs
which is a bad place to do that
apparently apparently you're supposed to
lay on their hips
because
riley's bored
really hates me
and uh yeah whenever someone gets like
subdued in uh in public everyone comes
out and everyone's like
trying to control the situation or
contribute or something
chinese forces fired
multiple ballistic missiles into water
bodies around taiwan
what a bunch of [ __ ]
they're just like threatening their
lives
look i can kill you if i want to
but yeah nancy pelosi recently went to
the land of
taiwan for no reason
she was like let's just go here now
so
so yeah i mean was there something
important there that she forgot maybe
she had to pick up some
dumplings
why the [ __ ] did you go there
now china's freaking out
just let them figure their [ __ ] out on
their own stop meddling
you know i'm sure chiang kai-shek was
funded by america
and foreign forces were trying to get
him to be in charge of america as a
puppet government
so i mean
i don't like china but i don't like
imperialism i think it's better that
there's uh
that they control themselves than if
american forces are in there just
[ __ ] with [ __ ]
but
you know
i think that uh right now it seems like
the people of taiwan don't want to be a
part of china so you should just let
them
do that china but obviously
they're not really interested in what
people want
so if more people in china want taiwan
to be a part of china then taiwanese
people want taiwan to be a part of
taiwan and not china then should you
invade taiwan
no you shouldn't because it doesn't
matter what the people in china think
it matters what people in taiwan think
uh but anyways
nancy pelosi went to taiwan
it's like
unless the taiwanese really wanted her
there
then
you shouldn't go
to taiwan because it just starts too
much [ __ ]
and it's like a statement like taiwan
should be able to get whoever they want
to visit them
but it's like sorry taiwan you don't get
to hang out with nancy pelosi i know
that's like a huge bummer
she probably knows how to party and
she's probably really fun
at buffets or whatever she's probably
really good at bingo
but
it's just one of the things that you
have to do without you know life is hard
and uh
you are
going to have to do without nancy pelosi
i know it's gonna be difficult
but
you're gonna have to find a way to
survive
just independently
without nancy pelosi helping you out
what do you think about nancy pelosi
going to taiwan
45
yeah
i should get going
well considering that i was on the
stream earlier and that pooped out i
have done almost an hour
uh thank you guys so much for tuning in
and have a good night and please
please
don't say hurtful things to